[Music]
on a stage in the back streets of
kharkiv they are busy rehearsing a play
about war
[Laughter]
not about the grim reality which haunts
this city
no this is a funny often moving
production about the personal life of a
soldier
it is designed to distract attention
from the threat they face and to show
that life with all its absurdities
continues here
the more we talk about the war the less
chance it will actually happen he says
so it's better to perform than have a
war
we do not want to think about politics
the theater is our life we want to think
we are helping people get over all of it
afghani tells me he thinks western
leaders are causing panic here
there is no tension at all life is going
on and in england from 1939 to 44 all
the theaters were working he says we are
not panicking
the theater manager reaches for the
words of england's most famous
playwright
william shakespeare said all the world's
a stage so the theater must continue
he also has a message for putin and
other world leaders
yes please stop hating each other and
just sit and negotiate these things he
says
the play about war has its premiere next
week all will be ready they say as for
the prospect of a real war they would
rather not think about that
at all
mark austin sky news kharkiv